我又不公布我的持仓
那如果用一句话来概括你的投资理念的话
是不是买股票就是买公司
是的
但是后面那句话就是
你要看懂公司
这个很难
是什么原因
或者什么样的思考
让你去
考虑投资英伟达这样的
看起来是一个
高度变化的行业中的一个企业
我以前也以为它高度变化了
后来发现它们确实很厉害
AI这个东西我觉得
至少掺和一下
不要错过了
你未来还有哪些愿望想要实现的
我这个人本来就胸无大志
我就过好每一天就挺好
大家好 我是方三文
也是雪球上的不明真相的群众
我对自己的简介是
陪聊陪赌
那么跟谁聊呢
有可能是跟上市公司的CEO聊
聊一聊他们公司的商业模式
他们的行业竞争力
也有可能是跟基金经理聊
聊他们的投资理念
投资框架和具体的投资的行为
也有可能跟经济学家聊
聊一聊他们对经济形势的看法
我可以把大家的问题带给他们
帮大家跟他们聊
也可以理解我是大家的代问人
我们就正式开始吧
有一个用户的问题开始
这个用户问了个特别无厘头的问题
你是如何度过平常的一天
比如说今天
打球啊
运动
天天如此吗
差不多吧
也没有什么
就是不同的球场打球
唯一变化的是这个球场的地点
还有打球的伙伴
伙伴有时候有 有时候没有
明白了
这个就是你的平淡无奇的一天
挺好 这没有什么平淡无奇
这就正常
那么刚才我说起
在中国南方的生活
也有用户想问你
这个叫“读书匠老张”的问题
他说小时候你是在什么样的环境下
长大的
这个成长的环境
跟你现在的性格 成就
有没有关系
这个就不知道了
我是在南昌出生的
那么六岁左右
跟父母下放
到江西安福县来
那么在安福县搬了五六个地方
一直在农村 一直最后
再搬回南昌旁边一个石岗
那就确实吃过苦
回石岗的时候就上中学了已经
从石岗考的大学
大学毕业以后分配到北京
工作了几年读了一个研究生
再去了广东
去了佛山再去了中山然后去了东莞
然后就来这了（加州）
我觉得可能这个用户他要问的
想问的细一点
你能不能描述一下
你的家庭环境啊
以及父母对你施加了怎么样的教育
这些东西其实没有太大意思
我在哪条河里摸过鱼
对他能有什么帮助
我很难讲的清楚
那我有
有哥哥有妹妹
那我们性格也各不一样
那父母到底有多大的帮助
其实我也不知道
但是简单讲呢
我觉得我父母确实对我
对我们吧 就对小孩子们都挺好
他不像
现在很多父母就很卷啊
就是逼小孩这个那个
我爸妈好像不太怎么管我
所以我小时候
就对我们很好
但是
没有太多的要求
一点点吧
所以我觉得我还是比较有安全感的
就不是说
怕这个怕那个
所以很多东西我自己是可以做决策的
我从小就
很习惯自己做决策
我觉得这点可能跟我的父母有很大的关系
你是有充分的自由的
你认为你对它是一个价值判断
认为这个是好的
我觉得可能父母对子女就
算是有充分的信任
也许是 就是我这么想的
或许他就是不管
不敢管我 谁知道
那我们再推一下现在你也是人的父母
你现在也是这样对你的子女的
我是的 我觉得我自己做不到的事情
我不要求小孩
就是他想玩
我那时候我也想玩
玩吧
但是
我发现小孩他们都挺自觉的
该做作业他做
该怎么样怎么样
边界的东西要告诉他
就什么东西你是不能做的
我觉得这个很重要
包括有的礼貌的东西呀
但是不是强求的
不是说天天就抓到小孩去训他
我觉得对小孩来讲
最主要给他们安全感很重要
没有安全感人很难理性
就是设定边界充分信任
是的
那么在你的童年和少年时期
你有过什么人生的目标吗
我没有什么目标
我觉得
我们那个年代本来我也不知道
反正我是没有
我这人一直胸无大志
我觉得自己就是普通人
能过好小日子就挺好
那也可以描述这个目标
就是把生活过好
我甚至都没有那么想
反正我就真的确实没有什么
我不是那种说自己非要干点事情
成就点啥
我还真没有那个想法
我就做我自己喜欢做的事情
我觉得就挺重要
你做自己喜欢做的事
你就比较开心
在你的童年和少年时代
有没有人这样描述过你
说你有跟别人不同的地方
没听说过
比如说这小子一看将来
我是记得上中学的时候
有过一个老师
确实
说段永平
你不能像他们那样
不学习 光贪玩
我就想我凭什么
我不知道为什么那个老师会这么讲
他可能觉得我读书还不错
我确实读书还不错
我后来考大学的时候
一突击就上去了
那确实我们那个年代
好多人大部分人是考不上大学的
所以那个老师可能是对的
但我也没辜负他
我还是考上大学
他是觉得你至少在学习能力方面
可能比别人强
所以他对你有一定的期望
那个是一件很奇怪的事情
因为那是个英语老师
我英语一塌糊涂
为什么他会觉得我学习能力强
我完全一头雾水
我的英文是上大学以后才学的
中学完全没有学ABCD
26个字母会
但是大概单词不超过24个
大概那个水平
就是完全没有学过英文
但是那个英文老师说
我跟别的小孩不一样
所以你这么讲
我就突然想起了
有人说你不一样的时候
你真的是会记住的
很有趣
但是为什么 不知道
也没有再交流
但这个东西至少对你是个激励
也没有
只是记得这件事情
我觉得好像没有觉得
这个事有什么了不起
你要不说我早忘了
你一说你看很有意思
我还就想起这事来了
那么你上的大学
本科学的是工科类的专业
你说的走的是理工男的这个路子
但是后来呢
你又去读了个研究生
应该说是叫商科吧
这个方面的
在这个过程中
是不是你觉得自己的这种
兴趣发生了一些变化
其实没有
首先我要强调
我读的不是商科
我读的是计量经济
实际上是经济类的
其实我认为也是工科的
它是一个
就是很逻辑的东西
商科是什么 不知道
没有正儿八经的学过
但是商科我觉得应该也是很多
也是逻辑的东西在里头
所以其实也很像
我不知道为什么要这么分啊
当初反正就是
因为我没有从事过技术
虽然我是学的工科
但是大学毕业以后
就分配到北京电子管厂
然后在干部科帮忙 帮了半年多
后来去了教育中心
当了成人教育的老师
教了两年多数学
然后就觉得没太大意思
后来有个机会考研
让我就给混上去了
反正就考上了
就考了人大
也是想换个口味
因为我对我学的工科的东西
我不是那么有兴趣
人是在探索
想办法找自己喜欢的东西
那我觉得
人大对我还是有帮助的
你在大学里面
可能在本科学了一些工科的基础知识
在人大学了一些经济学的知识
你觉得这里的学习
对你以后的人生影响大吗
我觉得大学里头最主要是学到了
学习的方法
就是你怎么去学习
然后你建立了一个信心
你碰到不懂的东西的时候
你是可以学会的
所以这样的话
你对未来的恐惧就会少很多
不然你什么都害怕
我确实见很多人
那也不是我们同学都行
我觉得他们用那智能手机
好像有时候打个字都打不会
我就觉得很奇怪
我以前也不会打字的
就发现
现在这么方便
就学一下呗
那些很快就学会了
也养成了学习的习惯
很重要
研究生我觉得
其实就等于你换了一个行当
然后多了一些不一样的知识
眼界也会有一点点不一样
但是其实最主要的就是
从原来那个地方出来了
因为我们那个时候是穷学生
你想出去看一眼都没钱的
那去读了个书
然后我又换了个新工作
就是研究生毕业以后
就去广东了
离开北京了
那么这过程当中
那都是在学习
当然也会吃很多苦
你觉得学到的具体的知识
可能是没那么重要的
学到的
我都不记得都学了什么
方法和态度
我觉得是有点作用
方法和你的这种
能够学会东西的这种信心很重要
就你碰到什么东西
你不会害怕
你会想着去学习
而不是感到恐惧
我觉得很多人是恐惧的
我让我妈妈学怎么用iPad
20年前就让她学
现在她肯定反正也不会学了
我妈已经100岁了
那么我觉得70多 80多的时候我让她学
她是坚决不学的
那些我学不会
她就认为她学不会
所以她就不学
其实那个东西很简单
我们也是学的
跟年龄其实没有关系
你研究生毕业以后
等于是南下广东了
当时这个决定是怎么做出的
你可能应该也有其他的选择
当时整个社会背景是怎么样的
确实我本来是可以留在北京的
有两个单位收我
后来刚好碰见有个广东的企业
在中关村招人
招人我就去了
去了那个地方也没那么理想
所以又再换到中山的
就是等于你做出了
南下广东的这个决定
某种程度上可以理解
你是投奔了市场
不是
我们其实走投无路
我们没有别的路可以选择
就是去尝试一下
那时候还年轻嘛
试一试总是好的
我觉得我是有一个习惯
就是我觉得不合适的东西
我要赶紧离开
那我觉得北京对我来讲不合适
我待着不舒服
广东怎么样我并不知道
那我不去我永远不知道
但是我知道我待在一个我不想待的地方
我觉得这个不合理
所以我就离开
我还曾经考虑过去海南的
后来了解过海南觉得
去海南不如去广东
所以我想有很多决策都是
如果你的决策是基于你很长远的去想
你的未来到底是想怎么样子的
你那个决策可能犯错误的概率就会低一些
很多人说你去广东
你将来养老怎么办
我说现在这年龄我养什么老啊
我得先出去看一看
当然你现在说
那就是我运气好
走对了路
但是实际上
中间很多决策都是
因为我觉得现在这个环境不舒服
我必须要离开
包括我到了广东以后
我的第一份工作也是
我三个月就离开了
我觉得那个我是走对了路
但是进错了门
我又离开了
然后去的中山
那么到了中山
后来就做成了小霸王
小霸王做得那么好
但是由于机制的问题
我觉得也不合适
我还是离开
能不能讲一讲
这个机制的不合适
主要具体是怎么样的
最早开始做的时候
说我们是有股份的
最早大老板说三七开
后来改二八了
后来说一九了
那我招人
我跟弟兄们都是有承诺的
最后发现我就没办法兑现这个承诺
那一九将来也是会没有的呀
那我到1994年
1995年的时候
我觉得这个肯定不行
所以我就决定
我就不干了
至于说不干了以后
又干了那是另外一件事情
所以它其实并没有必然的关联
这个不干了这里面
可能我理解
可能包括两部分
一部分是你希望有
股份这种形式的激励
第二个是
你跟他之间希望是有
好的契约关系之类
不是说有没有股份激励
因为一开始是有的嘛
那你没有契约
你就不可信了
不可信
你跟我讲什么都是不可信的
你有一次两次
难道你还要有第三次吗
就像你这个
刮那个瓶盖
刮出谢了
你还继续刮完它吗
你说两个字你刮出一个字
你肯定就不往下刮了吗
我就是刮到那个字
就觉得
这个我肯定不能再待下去了
你看我离开的时候
是30年前
那么离开了这个
小霸王之后
其实是到东莞去
创办这个步步高
那么你创办了
步步高的时候
是不是非常清晰的
解决了
小霸王那边的这个问题
小霸王的问题并不是它没有股份制
是它没有兑现这个承诺
那我们
我们当然不会有这个问题
所以我们并没有解决那个问题
我们从开始就没有那个问题
我们是什么样就是什么样的
我们一直都就大家合作的都挺好
说什么就是什么
所以大家很放心
彼此有很高的信任
我想原来那大老板也是后悔的
你再回头看
如果在小霸王当时的那个架构下面
你觉得有没有可能达到一种
比较理想的治理状态
我不知道怎么回答这个问题
因为事实上没有
那怎么才能够理想
我不知道
因为那个不是我的问题
那是别人的问题
我并没有说因为利益的问题离开
我是认为因为信任的问题
其实我那个时候收入就已经很好了
但是没有太大的意思
你要说财富自由我那时候就财富自由
我们其实分成它也是分的
只是它将来会怎么样
我不知道
它有没有办法建立股份制
有没有办法让你感觉到
它这个机制是保障你的
就像你看到有一些公司
给股东分红都好像是恩赐一样
那我觉得这个没有道理
给股东分红那就是股东本来就该拿的
那我员工拿到的分红就是员工该拿的
就像我们发奖金的时候
有人说谢谢老板
我说这话不合适
因为这是按契约发的奖金
你不需要谢我的
谢这个东西呢
虽然大家顺口觉得拿到钱
应该谢一下
这个谢的不是地方
那我再问个问题
在创办步步高的时候
你有没有有意识的去创造
你喜欢的企业文化
企业文化跟创始人有很大的关系
它是一个你自己的个人品性
然后你是找那些认同你的人
认同你的文化的人
所以我们的企业文化其实就是
大家一堆人
大家都认同了这个文化
所以大家一起待下来了
那不认同的人
慢慢就会被淘汰掉
会离开
并不是说
我从一开始写了一张纸
然后照本宣科
让大家一点一点弄下去
我们很多文化也是在
整个成长的过程当中
也是在不停的进化
包括我们的
不为清单
也是一条一条加上去的
不能做的事情
我们也是要通过很多
血的教训才知道
然后知道这个事不能做
我们以后就不做了
该怎么做事情
学习的曲线
这些东西也是
也是慢慢慢慢的学
我们公司
从我离开以后
因为我离开很久了
不做CEO 20多年了嘛
那确实
不可同日而语
现在很厉害
我们那个时候
其实就是一个很小的公司
但我们那时候其实也挺厉害
小霸王的时候我们就挺厉害
你说的逐步形成的企业文化
因为现在也积淀了很多年了
你能够把它简单的概括一下吗
我觉得我们
最主要就是
你看我们一直讲本分
诚信
讲用户导向
我们的东西其实都很大白话的
我们的愿景是叫做
更健康更长久
其实就不健康不长久的事不做
其实就是很平常心的东西
没有什么要怎么着
要做500强啊
要这个要那个啊
虽然500强也不算什么
现在可以找到的资料啊
也是一个用户提供的
他说 你大学三年级的时候
就想到了这个本分文化
有这个事吗
大三的时候我是
无意中看到德鲁克的一句话
叫做做对的事情
和把事情做对
那个对我触动很大
一下就把这个是非的东西给拿出来了
你发现凡是你只要花五秒钟
想一下这个事情
你一辈子会省好多事
像我们公司如果说
坐下来说要讨论这个
有没有钱挣的时候
有时候会有一句话叫
这是不是件对的事情
就如果感觉不对的事情
我们很容易就停止
如果你只是讨论有没有钱挣
你就会发现很复杂
就因为很多事情
你事先你并不知道
但是有些事情是不对的事情
你可能很早的时候
你是会知道的
当然有些事情你事后知道
知道了也没有关系
你以后不做就行了
所以我们是会攒一些的
我可以给你举个简单的例子
你比方说我们想过
我们不做代工
那这个不是什么原则
你因为做代工也可以
也可以挣钱
但是我就觉得那个不符合我们
我们不擅长做这个
然后我记得有一次郭台铭
跟我聊天
他就问我这个问题说
我说我们有个不为清单
他说举个例子
我说我们不做代工
他说哦 那什么意思
我说你看我要做代工
打不过你对不对
他说那倒是
但是我们做品牌我们做得很好
我们企业也不比他们做得小
但是我们不是靠代工
跟他竞争的
那代工你看做得好
台积电做得多好
那不是说代工不行
只是代工对我们来讲是不合适的
所以我们就停止
所以你任何人来找我们做代工的生意
我们就很简单就不做
等于你们有一个
是非的一个价值观在前面
后来才是怎么做的方法论
是的
因为学习是有代价有曲线
你可能会犯错
所以你要做对的事情
然后把事情做对的过程当中
你犯的错误是可以接受的
但是你做了错的事情
你带来的恶果
那是不应该的
因为你明知是错的事情
你为什么要去做呢
当然你说你事先不知道
那你下一次不再做
也是一个很重要的东西
这样你以后
你几十年积累下来
你就少犯很多错误
也不会在原地折腾
这里面有个叫“学习机器”的用户
问的也是这个问题
他的问题比较长
他这么说的
他说拥有共同价值观的人
主要是培养出来的
还是选择出来的
选择出来
选择出来的
然后他说
你在步步高里面有各位大佬
这些优秀的人
是不是不一定是刚工作的时候
就被你认出来
而是可能长期跟你一起工作的时候
被熏陶出来的
我觉得我们
大部分人跟我都差不多
都是普通人
那么大家有认同的价值观
当然你受过大学教育
你学习还可以
都是小学霸
那他后面的东西
都是慢慢的学习积累下来的
但是价值观认同是非常重要的
价值观要是不认同
互相不认同
这事没法干
就是干不长的
大家都各打各的小算盘
肯定是要出问题
我觉得我们公司
你看我们三十年回去
我们好多老同事
都是从进了公司
就一直在一直到退休
有些还在工作的
这个人最后问题是
把一个人放在一个好的文化里面
他会不会变成好的人的概率高一点
就是可不可塑造的
我觉得很难
这可能会有一点点帮助
人心里头都有善有恶
他就发现
有人到这
发现你这个环境挺好
那就是我们唤醒了
他善的那一部分
或者说
他的价值观正确的那一部分
他把恶的那一部分就藏起来了
但是很恶的人你没有办法改变
不是每个人都
改变人是非常难的一件事情
按你这个说法
也是跟刚才说的
做对的事情
也是找对的人
选择还是比那个重要
但是找对的人
其实也是通过时间来的
比如说
找对的人你分两种
一种是
不对的人
你慢慢把他淘汰掉
还有一种
他善恶都有
可能他说的那个也有道理
他认同了你的文化之后
他觉得待下来
他舒服
他慢慢的他就跟着你就走了
所以我们一直都说
我们有两种人一个叫同道中人
一个叫同行中人
他认同你了
他虽然他搞不清楚
但是反正你让我这样做
我就这样做
反正别的方案我就不做了
但是这些人他有时候不小心
还会出点娄子
但是你一说他想
哦 OK 是哦
以前我们讲过
他也能够回来
待得时间很长的人
就是有这样的机会的
尤其是像
你像代理商
客户这些东西
跟我们其实没有
像我们公司内部的人
对文化的熏陶那么多
但是其实我们这些
代理商这么多年下来
其实也都很好
大家对文化的认同还是很强的
那我再问一个
除了人之后的
企业具体经营的问题
我觉得可能对这个步步高系来说
它有个非常大的变化是
后来做了智能手机
原来是做过别的电子产品
后来做过功能机
后来做了智能手机
这是一个很大的变化
这个决策过程
我听你以前说过
好像最开始你是不赞成的
对
那这个后来是怎么变成又做的
没有 我们的CEO
因为他们是CEO
我赞不赞成不影响
他们做不做决定
所以
当初其实就是沈炜
因为OPPO是后做的
步步高手机是先做的
后来改名叫VIVO
那大家也是走投无路了
就是现在自己做的产品
看起来
像我们做电话机
一年就做到全国第一了
两年吧 最多
后来觉得这个市场再做下去
我们好像也没有太大的前景
然后手机来了
沈炜就觉得我们应该做手机
我那时候觉得我们手机
可能做不过那些
什么松下 索尼
后来又出来摩托罗拉
那这个是功能机时代的事情
功能机时代
然后他说
阿段不是的
他说这个手机
他最后说服我的
他说这个手机其实是一个
个性化非常强的东西
我原来是想它跟家电一样
人家规模比我们大
我们很难打得过别人
我说如果你认为
它是很个性化的东西
那我们就有机会
我们能够做出差异化的
我们能够做的跟别人不一样
我们在有的地方
可以做的比别人好
加上我们做企业
已经有很多年的经验了
我说但是不管怎么样
我们公司的规矩就是这样
不管我反不反对
CEO做的决定
就是他们做的决定
结果也是他们来
自己承受的
他不能说阿段反对
所以我没做
我没有责任
我只是作为一个顾问的角色
所以其实这个可能
很多人不太理解
以为我是个老板
我其实我在公司早就不是
我甚至当CEO的时候
我就不太管
都是让他们做决定
所以他们接过来也是很顺
放权是要很长时间的
但可能是不是从
做功能机到智能机
是一个更大的决定
那个不是什么决定
那个是被逼的
你功能机卖不动了
我们差点都死在上面了
虽然我们前面
功能机已经做得非常好了
但是智能机来得非常的凶猛
就那么一瞬间
就把市场基本上占了
那我们那时候手里
还有好多功能机
所以三十年（庆）的时候
大家也是很感慨
就是我们渡过去了
因为我那时候还专门回去过
因为我们存了很多物料的
当时的现金消耗得非常的快
我们账面有
我记得有七八十个亿的现金
看着往下掉
掉到最后就快到底了
又开始回来了
因为那时候智能机已经出来
我们智能机一代两代差不多
我们就缓过来了
所以我们中间有一年的时间
就是2012年到2013年中间
那一年的时间
我们亏了不少钱
当时我回去就说
如果我们要倒的话
不要倒得太难看
也看过别人倒
倒完了以后就是一地鸡毛
我说这不行
不能让供应商吃亏
也不要让员工吃亏
当然我说那个东西
其实我是有一点底气的
因为我投资这一块一直都没有动
就相当于我们的后备役部队一样
一直都没有上
最后也没有上
所以还挺好
反正弟兄们也真的是很争气
那就是做回来
从功能机往智能机转的过程中
其实比从做电话到做手机
要面临过更大的危机
因为规模太大
规模太大了
我觉得我们也是有失误的
就是不够敏感
因为在功能机上做得很好了
我们其实是有风险承受能力的
但是那一次确实亏得也挺多
以前也犯过类似的错误
但是规模没有那么大
所以缓过来也挺快
那么最大的风险其实是功能机滞销
是的
我们有太多的物料
就备货备太多了
是的
没想到它的销量会下滑得这么厉害
它那个降的速度太快了
因为我们过去的经验曲线是
认为它慢慢降的
因为其实我们早就在开发智能机
也知道这个趋势
但是功能机还是下了很多单
总觉得这是有一个过程的
没想到它就
一瞬间就过去了
像现在AI上来的
你看这两年的时间AI上了多少
这个道理有点像
新技术推动的新的产品
它的这种普及程度比想象中快
你也可以这么说吧
也可以这么说
主要是新的产品确实很好
它一下就把老的产品完全替代了
而且智能机出来以后
它不光是替代了这些东西
你看多少东西被替代
相机
相机没了
我们
像我们做学习机这个部门
基本上我们做的什么电子词典
什么复读机什么学习机
基本上都被手机替代
因为智能机
它已经现在是一个
非常大的一个产业了
我回想起我的一些经历
我觉得我大概可能在
2004 2005年
2003 2004年的时候
我看过摩托罗拉那一款手机叫308（注：应为6188）
其实已经有智能机的雏形
最愚蠢的智能机
后来有一个诺基亚的E71
更愚蠢
但是它也是智能机的一个雏形
但是它是
你应该叫它是弱智机
诺基亚做那一款
我印象非常深
我拿到了很兴奋
但是发现他们好弱智
它以前我们用诺基亚手机
用的很习惯的
它把界面全改了
我拿上来不会用
那你想我一学工的人
在那折腾半天都不知道怎么用
我说这帮设计的人
脑子真是有病
所以诺基亚最后倒了一点都不意外
我觉得这公司的文化肯定是烂掉了
但是我觉得它毕竟在那个地方走出了一步
虽然最后没成功
是不是我们可以这样理解
也许它那个企业里面
也有人对这个产品的趋势
是有一些相对正确的判断的
产品趋势都没有问题
谁都看得见
但是它的文化很重要
就是它企业没这个能力
它们这个企业太注重市场占有率了
太注重生意
它不太注重用户
所以它才会有那么大的miss
我就觉得
而且它后来又miss了一次
其实安卓出来的时候
谷歌是去找过他们的
是希望诺基亚转安卓
他们不干
他们要守住他们自己那个东西
终于把自己给守死了
所以这个没办法
那现在我们反正
至少像摩托罗拉 诺基亚
曾经是知名度非常高的企业
也曾经认为
他们在管理方面很有经验
那我就想看你
管理救不了一家公司
它在战略上在文化上出问题了
我就回头从管理方面
我记得你曾经是
比较推崇松下的管理的
后来是不是你对这个看法也有些变化
松下还是蛮厉害的一家公司
但是我觉得
它这个大文化
日本这种大文化
可能我不知道
我觉得不是特别容易理解
有些东西
我们其实最早
我是去找过松下
想跟他们合作做手机的
我跟陈明永跟沈炜两个人去松下
一直从科长 部长
一直见到了中村社长
然后我跟他们
因为我们是他们的客户
他们知道我们是谁
他不是说
不然也不会见到社长
然后我就跟他们讲
他们就问我们的来意
我说我们其实是觉得
首先当时我们对自己
不是说太有信心
对技术 对资金的来源
对后面的会发生什么事
还是有点不太有底的
就觉得找一个
比较大一点的公司合作
可能说不定会更有机会
所以我那时候
我去松下 我跟他们讲过
我说那以我们的实力
我认为我们合作的话
我们三年做到
我说我们两年做到前三名
三年做到前两名
都是很有可能的 在中国市场
从头到尾没有任何一个人问过我
你为什么这么认为
没有人在乎
所以我离开松下我就知道
我觉得松下他们其实是很麻烦的
他们根本就不信任你
完全没有想
有人说这个话
你总得有个人问我
你凭什么 对不对
那我才可以说
你不问 我不会说的
我觉得松下那公司这方面的
这个我不知道叫什么
就是很官僚的东西
包括我见到社长
社长跟我讲的时候
当我在做一个决策的时候
我就想着松下老人站在我背后会怎么想
我心想那你就完蛋了 对不对
因为松下老人早就不在了
你看乔布斯跟蒂姆·库克讲
说 你当CEO就是你做决策
你不要想我乔布斯会做什么
这就对了
就像我也是这样跟大家讲
就是他们是CEO 他们做决策
一定不要想阿段会怎么做
你要那么想 我们就完了
我们早就完了 不会等到今天
所以我觉得
松下的文化我觉得确实是出了问题
但是按你这么描述的话
它可能把自己过往的体制 成就
可能看得太重了
这个我不知道
我没有关心过发生什么事
我就觉得它那样不对
尤其是一个社长跟我讲
他在做决策的时候想着
老社长站在背后怎么想
我觉得他们背了很重的负担
因为你的眼睛是要看到用户的
他的眼睛是看倒后镜的
那你时间足够长
它一定是会出毛病的
那么按你刚才的描述
你是很早
首先你建立了很好的授权机制
很早的时候就让合作伙伴自己去决策
然后你自己也很早的退出了
具体的经营管理的决策
好像在企业家里面并不常见这么安排的
这跟我有什么关系
我又不是常见的企业家
我并不关心别人想干什么
我想打球
别人想打球他们也可以到处打
那最主要的是他们干得比我好
我觉得他们比我的动力要强
我觉得我该干的事我都干过
然后我还有其他享受的事情
然后他们干的又比我好
我为什么要待在那个地方
而且我很信任他们
我觉得这点很重要
我也不怕他们犯错误
但是我看到的很多的企业家
他希望自己一直在一线
这跟我没有关系
不在乎他们想什么
那么你觉得
这也是一个用户的问题
他说创始人
这个叫“路边边走”的用户问的
他说创始人老板离开公司
他有什么办法怎么判断
可以离开了或者条件成熟了
他觉得可以离开的时候就是可以离开
但是很难
不是很多人可以做到这一点
难在哪里呢
难在他不想
他要想的话他总是能找到办法
那这样他也不会对公司有太大的好处
那是因为他自己享受这个事情
这个其实无可非议
我不觉得这个东西有什么好讨论的
有些人他喜欢做这件事情
我喜欢让弟兄们做
我觉得其实就是一个选择
你说不选又想羡慕我的生活
你又想享受你的生活
那做不到啊
有些人是喜欢工作的
我是真不喜欢
但是从结果上来看
这个是个客观结果
是可以评判的嘛
一方面我觉得
人很敬业
一直在工作好像是一种好的品质
但同时我们又不能否认
随着人的年龄的增长
他的能力是会下降的
是不是总的来说
还是得承认人对企业
即使是创始人对企业的贡献
他也是阶段性的
我不认为可以这么想
我觉得这个没有道理
这个是很没有逻辑的想法
那巴菲特90多岁了
人家做得也挺好啊
我给一个反例嘛
工科的人
但你们文科可能不这么想
1234 ABCD 甲乙丙丁
你可以说很多
我工科只要举一个反例
你就否定
那巴菲特90多岁了
CEO还做着呀
刚刚退休
那我觉得
他为什么退了我不知道
我觉得他可能身体没有以前那么好
我前两年去见他
他带我们参观办公室
是带着我们一堆人走的
走了50多分钟
所以那个时候他身体还不错
最近我不知道
但是我看他开股东大会其实还OK
他是觉得也许确实该交班了
所以这个逻辑是不存在的
巴菲特是一个特别典型的例子
他就是喜欢做这件事情
他就一直在做
你为什么非要因为年龄就退休呢
我不觉得年龄就一定是一个障碍
但他自己要对自己有个评价
你要自己都啥也记不住了
做个决策也是晕晕乎乎的
那我就不知道
但是如果是你自己的公司
你愿意
其实别人也没有可说的东西
我就是觉得我们
弟兄们
因为我们那个
其实不是一天两天的事情
我之前就这样
其实我在当CEO的时候
他们就已经很多自主权了
所以我交给他们可是自然而然的事情
我很少在办公室
我要么就去打球 要么就去打球
好 OK
这也是一个用户叫“一根白”
这个用户问
第一次接触股票投资
是什么契机
这还需要契机吗
天天到处都知道有股票
我只是说退休了以后
后来就搬到这来生活了
就觉得那我也不能天天24小时打球
然后我也不会去找份工作
那这个更没有道理
后来就想着
这投资好像
好像跟生意有关跟企业有关系
我就来研究研究
也买了很多书
包括看图看线
看不懂
觉得我这一工科出来的人
怎么这图我就看不懂
他们就能得出这样的结论
那样的结论
我说这些结论在逻辑上都是不成立
后来直到我看了老巴的东西
其实啥也没看
就看你买股票就是买公司
我就看到那一句话
我就突然就明白了
这句话就够了
就够了
因为剩下的就是你怎么看公司
那不是老巴能够教的
你不懂企业
跟你讲多少理论也是白讲
但是我毕竟我做企业出来的
我懂别人的生意
也是相对来讲容易的
但是我也懂不了太多的生意
这些年也没找到好多个
就是那么几个呗
但是我觉得懂生意很重要
不懂生意投资是很难做的
那如果用一句话来概括你的投资理念的话
是不是买股票就是买公司
是的
没有了
就够了
对
但是后面那句话就是
你要看懂公司
这个很难
为什么说投资很简单
但是不容易
简单就是你一定要看公司
你一定要看懂生意
你也要看懂未来的现金流
难是难在
你很难做到这一点
大部分公司都不容易看懂
那么我记得是巴菲特还是芒格说过
他说一辈子投资的话
如果是有个打孔机
打20个孔
这好像是巴菲特说的
你的额度用完了吗
我应该还没有
还没有
没有
那我们说的更具体一点
有时候小仓位的买一点股票
那个不太算
我就说有财务意义上的投资决策
你这个20个孔
你感觉现在自己打了多少个了
我可以数得出来
我自己真的投过
比较大金额的
就说大比重吧
这么说
最早是网易
网易
然后
雅虎应该算
但是我后来
其实本质上是投的阿里巴巴
我雅虎其实就是想买阿里
这个算一个
后来差不多就到苹果了吧
伯克希尔哈撒韦
伯克希尔哈撒韦我的比重也不大
苹果比较大
茅台其实也蛮大的
腾讯
我现在其实
还可以吧
通用电气算不算
通用电气没有那么算
通用电气就是在2008年
危机的那一下
确实投了一下
我现在想不起比重来了
但是
过去以后
他们换CEO以后
我就很快就退出了
我觉得按今天的想法
我是不会投通用电气
我觉得通用电气的商业模式并不好
我那个时候还没有
没有现在的水平
我们还先数数孔
看看
谷歌算一个孔吗
谷歌其实都不算
我没有在谷歌上
真的下过重注
拼多多算吗
拼多多可以算
好像在这个之外再找孔
就不怎么找得到了
不多了
我要想一下
因为拼多多是很特殊了
是因为我
在早期的时候
就是这叫什么
初创阶段的时候就已经投了
就天使
所以我投的钱其实
比重很少
这赚的钱确实很多
严格意义上其实都不算
因为我不是说我看懂了往里投
我是稀里糊涂投的
那如果再想不出别的孔的话
听起来就10个孔还没打完
差不多吧
小10个孔
所以我还有很久可以做投资
因为要做够20个
可能全世界
投资人里面
二级市场的投资人里面
敢说自己20个孔的额度
没用完的人可能也很少
这不知道
这看你的定义
那我就说真的
你到20个孔
你至少要占到你的这个决策里头
有些人一辈子其实都到不了
他就没有
重仓过任何公司
他最高的重仓就是5个点
或者他手里拿
甚至很有名的投资的人
比方说彼得·林奇
他一辈子做过2000多个股票
他一定很忙
所以头发白得也很早
早早的就退休了
比我还早
我不知道他现在还做不做投资
他估计现在还做
就自己给自己做
他不管别人
他不工作
我不知道
其实取决于定义
那我碰过的股票可能也很多
像我还买过神华呢
我不是买过神华
我现在有神华
只是它比重不大
那茅台我是比重比较大
我一般跟大家讲
我就三只股票
苹果 腾讯 茅台
差不多真是这样
大概反正就是说
可以无争议的结论
就是这20个孔没用完
关键看你那个孔的定义是什么
那老巴他碰过的股票
也不止20个
但他真正重仓
他跟你说的这些股票
其实是不多的
甚至说他赚到特别大钱的
苹果肯定也算嘛
不知道现在卖得怎么样
有哪个孔是你
你觉得打了孔
其实现在你总体上不是很满意
不会有这样的现象
因为你不满意
你赶紧就跑了呀
它就已经不在你孔那里了
现在还是孔的
都是满意的
逻辑上是
只是
不然逻辑上不成立
你不喜欢
你还拿着
这跟小孩不一样
你不喜欢
你还得留着
那股票你不喜欢
你可以用脚投票的
那我们接下来把它说细一点
你刚才说
理解买股票就是买公司
这个理念是容易的
但是要搞懂一家具体
不容易
理解这句话非常难
我看
你在雪球上那些球友们
能有1%的人真懂这句话
就了不起
做到就更难
但是做不到的人
也是能挣钱的
他倒不一定是他不懂
他根本他理解就不是这个
我说的就是这个意思
所以这理解不是这个
不就是不懂吗
当你懂了以后
你就不会受市场影响
如果你还天天看市场
天天看动态
天天看过去怎么样
哪怕是很大V的人我看见
一天到晚
在讲市场怎么样
市场怎么样
他就是不懂
他要是懂的话
你看我什么时候讲市场
什么时候我在雪球上说
今天要涨了
明天要掉了
那你就肯定是不懂
当然这是我的理解
不懂他不等于不挣钱
投资这个东西很有意思
你闭着眼睛买一只拿着
你100个人里头
其实是有50个人可以挣钱
那这50个人就可以出来讲
我是因为这样挣了钱
你这个东西
但是你要让他重复
他就没有那么容易
但是你要是做投资生意的人
他只要拿到钱
你其实很简单
我可以教大家一个赚钱的办法
你就买标普500指数
你最后总是赚钱
但是这不等于你就懂了吗
但是你要是真的这样做
其实也表示你是懂了
对
那我们再接下来说
如果认同了这个东西
或者懂了这个东西
就是搞懂公司还是很难
那人家问的是
比如说怎么样确定
怎么样搞懂一个公司
怎么确定自己搞懂公司
我们就以网易为例
你怎么样把它搞懂了
怎么样确定自己搞懂
就是你想我本身做游戏出身
然后我一看他们
我跟他们游戏团队聊聊
觉得他们是一帮很热爱游戏的人
他们真的很认真
这是第一
第二 这个商业模式
我看着我觉得它很有道理
加上它的现金比市值高
当时啊
那我作为风投一样的
我买进去很简单
加上当时有这个契机
刚好股票就低成那个样子
大家都是恐慌性的
觉得他们要完蛋了
那我觉得他们大概率是有机会挣钱的
刚好我账上有点现金
我就都
我是满仓买了网易
6个月涨了20倍
那你想我当然是觉得
怎么说呢
你说我看懂了吗
我要看懂了
我应该把整个网易买下来啊
所以懂这个东西
我也不知道是什么意思
但是我大致上是觉得
他们是能挣钱的
我觉得我的投资风险不会
不会说特别大
但是我说账上的钱其实
就账上有点现金
不是很大的比重
也不公平了
就为什么你能够拿到那么久
赚了那么多钱你还不卖
问题那些钱对我来讲它并不多
所以我可以比较理性的去想一件事情
如果我只有那么多钱
我还真保不住我也可能卖掉
所以保持理性是一件很难的事情
那么对网易的判断里面
它包括了
听起来包括了两个部分
一 你对这个游戏这个商业
本身有个判断
觉得它是能挣钱的
那当然 我是谁啊
我做游戏出身的呀
我可懂游戏了
还包括一个对它的定价
比如说它的股价很低啊
比如说可能低于它的持有的净现金
这个其实也是老巴说的
什么安全边际
老巴的安全边际不是指这个
安全边际指的是你对公司有多懂
这是我的理解
不是说有多便宜
便宜东西可以更便宜的
当时我就是觉得
他们是有机会赚钱
但是并不知道它能赚多少
我要知道它能赚今天这么多钱
我哪怕晚一点
我也会多买
我也不会卖
我后来也是卖掉的
说明表示我其实也没有那么懂
那么懂和不懂
其实按你这么说
其实它处于一个灰色的区域
不是那么清晰的一个标准 是这样吗
我也不知道
但是
到处问人家的人肯定是不懂的
但是不问的人呢
是不是就懂了
你可以说它属于灰色地带
至少我赚了100多倍嘛
那你说我懂还是不懂
我卖肯定有我卖的原因
有卖的道理
而且我其实也没少赚
因为我有其他的
我觉得也很好的投资标的
那我们再说另一个标的
我倾向于认为是不是你投资的
目前的占比最大的
就是苹果这个公司
这个公司
你投资的金额大
赚的钱也多
有个用户叫“莉莉安78”他问
15年前苹果是一个卖硬件的公司
现在利润一半硬件一半软件
这个商业模式的变化
你买的时候
是不是就有这个判断
我是2011年买的
那个时候已经很清晰了
就是你当时能判断
类似平台业务
这个软件的业务
它会创造更多的利润
我是这个行当里头的
我怎么会不知道
那都不是叫判断
那是一个你看得见的一个东西
水桶里的鱼
那倒谈不上
但至少是一个不远处的大象吧
你不需要判断
你就知道那就是一头大象
就能看见
能看得见了
我们自己就在做这个生意
我当然能看见
那可以这样子判断
苹果的商业模式是很好的话
我觉得好像
你在企业文化方面
对苹果好像也是有一个判断
是这样吗
对 我觉得他们企业文化很好
那你能说一说
你为什么认为他的企业文化很好
我觉得他们用户导向做的很好
他们不是那种很生意导向的公司
他们非常的在乎把东西做好
非常的在乎用户体验
非常的在乎怎么改善
非常的想得很长远
所以 他们给用户提供不了
价值的东西
或者提供不了足够价值的产品
你再热门他们也不会做
你看我给你举个特别简单的例子
我们发生过争论 对不对
你说苹果到底会不会出大屏
我说他们一定会
你还记得吗
我记得
记得吧
但是我们等了三年才出来
但是我怎么就知道它会出大屏
我怎么知道它会出大屏
你能回答这个问题吗
我觉得因为大屏是用户的需求
对啊
我们做这行的
我们大屏都出来了
那苹果
所以我就知道用户是一定会要大屏的
但是我没想到他们扛了三年
这个事情就是我也是很困惑的
就是因为我们这些用户
买了手机的
我从来没有困惑过
我就知道他们犯错误了
他们停在
蒂姆·库克在这个地方犯了一个非常大的错误
就是
他有点像中村
乔布斯说过
这个是最好的
所以他们就不屑去做
其实他们早就在研究
研究室里头所有的大屏它都有的
但是他们就是没有推
当然他们可能也有些是因为
觉得性能还不够好
或者什么原因
我不知道
反正最后它不推了
那我另外给你再举个例子
最早的时候他们说要做iTV
就是
电视机啊
不是Apple TV
Apple TV是小盒子
机顶盒嘛
有人跟我讲
我记得打球的时候
信誓旦旦告诉我
他们一定会做 样品都看见了
我说他们一定不会
他们问我为什么
我说他们能做什么
我用同样的话
跟我公司的人也讲过
因为我们也做电视
他们后来就把它砍掉了
后来刘作虎上来
又做了一次
又砍了一次
我说咋回事刘作虎
我当年就跟你讲过的
我们为什么不做电视
他非要再尝一下
陈明永还让他试了
陈明永就当年我让他试一样
他也就让
其实你看我们的风格还是很像的
他并没有说不允许你做
你要做就做
试完他觉得确实不对
因为它没有办法提供
太有价值的东西
最后一个
十几年前
到处就在说苹果
要出苹果车
电动车
我说它们绝不会有这个电动车的
最后很多人说不可能
他说它们都在做了
我说它们做不出来
不是技术的问题
是它们到底能干什么
那么大个车
苹果能够提供的价值
非常的有限
它卖什么价
它是不是最后要卷入
这样那样的
它就没有足够的差异化
这是我对苹果比一般人了解的地方
很多人跟我讲
这不可能
它们苹果车就快出
就快出
我说如果出
我很高兴
我很想看到它们到底能做什么
但是我就是认为它们做不出来
直到最近
我到纽约
碰到苹果店的那个老板
是苹果店的老板
不是苹果的老板
他告诉我
他们那个店停了三年
改了一次
是准备卖苹果车的那个改法
后来又改回来
我说原来你们其实早就知道
它们不卖苹果车的
他们至少提前一年到两年
就知道这个事
但是苹果其实没有宣布
由于某些原因 我不知道
我一听我觉得
它们还真是做过苹果车
其实这个都超出我想象的
我以为它们只是在研究呢
它们其实真的打算做
但是它们真的最后没有做
所以它出来的时候我很高兴
我说哎
你看果然像我说那样
其实这就是它的文化
它的文化就是
它发现它的产品没有办法给用户增加
足够的价值的时候
它们就不碰了
它们不会为了生意去做
它们要是为了做生意的话
它完全可以做一个车
它要做车
你想
也不会有谁比它做的更好
至少它也会跟最好的电动车差不多好
我想它是肯定可以做得到
它那么有钱有人
它完全可以做得到
但是它到底最后会怎么样
我不知道
我觉得这是我的理解
我觉得这家公司的文化还是蛮好的
当然好文化的公司也不少啊
但是它也可能也会犯错
当然每个人都会犯错
就比如说刚才你举的做大屏手机
三年没做
然后差一点做的苹果车
文化好
最主要的就是它
叫做最终它会走回正道
因为它是有一个
就叫做有一个北斗星在指引着它
它到底该干什么
不是为了生意
为了生意
你仅仅是讨论生意是很容易犯错误的
如果有好的文化的话
是并不能完全避免犯错
但是可能犯了错误
那当然
被纠正的概率
没有好的文化呢
其实犯错误的概率
大家其实都差不多的
只是说你犯不犯下去
还有就是你有没有不为清单
那我们上了
停止做的事情
那我们犯这一类错误概率就小了嘛
所以我们三十年下来
我们犯的错误就比其他人少
我觉得其实最主要的就是这个东西
你看我在
雪球上不写的那一条嘛
人们关心的是我们做过什么
其实我们之所以成为我们
很大的原因是因为我们不做的那些事情
因为不做
因为我们知道这个事对我们不合适
我们就不做了
那不做我们不就少犯很多错误嘛
那你攒下来的
不就是做对的事情的概率就大了
其实就是小小的一点点的差别
可能差30年就是很大的差别
那么现在价格的苹果 你觉得投资
不便宜
不便宜是吧
就是从投资回报率的
也不可能寄予很高的期望
是的
那也看用户本身
他的机会成本是多少
他如果把钱存在银行里
拿一个多点的利息的话
那你还真不如买苹果
但是
你可以一年赚个十几个点
那你可能真的就没必要买苹果
苹果最后有没有发展
其实我也不知道
苹果其实它还是一直都很强的
它有那么多的用户
AI最后落地在哪
不还是要在手机上嘛
那苹果将来再翻一倍两倍三倍都是有可能的
但是我不知道
不是说它就一定不行
但是它不便宜
好的
你也曾经在2008年的时候
买过通用电气
后来你认为是
对它的看法是有些变化的
对它的看法的变化
主要是在商业模式还是企业文化方面
以前我觉得是在企业文化上
因为商业模式其实我一直就没看懂
但企业文化我以前喜欢
它们说的这个时代在变
唯一不变成是诚信
它们对诚信特别强调
然后我后来我去看它们主页上
我找不到这句话了
我从找不到那句话开始我就决定卖了
我就觉得它们都不再强调这件事情
我就觉得好奇怪啊
加上商业模式我确实看不懂
它们买太多的公司
买卖公司
最早的是因为受杰克·韦尔奇的影响
觉得这家公司好神奇
后来发现其实也没有谁是神奇的
这是不是对杰克·韦尔奇这个人你可能都祛魅了
我倒也谈不上
我不了解
还好是卖了呀
你想那个时候
我卖的时候4000多个亿市值
现在可能
都不到了
那你想我把那个换成苹果
那多大差别啊
我大概拿了有
我都不记得两三年三四年
没有拿太久
但这单业务也是挣了钱的
犯错误有时候也是会挣钱的
所以
我觉得那是一个错误
回到今天我是不会买
即使挣了钱你也不能否认它是个错误
它当然是个错误
因为它不符合我后来
决定的你要符合企业文化
就是商业模式 企业文化
这两个过滤器
再问一个公司
你曾经包括可能现在应该还持有西方石油
你也说这个是
抄的老巴的作业
它是
但是
这有一些历史的东西在里头
因为我以前呢
受另外一个朋友的影响
我买过油气指数
因为他告诉我
那个东西呢
因为那个时候我觉得
那油气指数掉得太离谱了
那个油不可能长期一直这样掉下去
我就问他我说哎
这个指数跟油气本身的价格
有多大的关联度
他说99个点
哦 我说那很好啊
那我就买了长期拿着嘛
这个朋友是不是搞错了
没有
他没错
但是他后来跟我
我后来再问他你说的是怎么个关联
他说每一天
我一想 完了
这每一天99%
那个差别就大了
不是长期了
他这个短线的操作
然后我就仔细的就关注了一下
发现他其实他是要买期指啊
买期权啊 买期货啊
他其实都是在买期权的
那我现在长期肯定是不能
损耗成本是很高的
时间损耗非常大
那我就卖了啊
我那个时候其实投了不少钱
投了完了也不算很多
但是差不多有一个亿的美金
但是亏了1000多万
我一看到这个东西想通了
就是你看错的事情
你要马上改一下
我就通通都卖掉
都卖了以后呢亏了1000多万啊
1000万出头吧
但是就有个小情结说哎呀
那个油这个东西确实不好搞
然后
看到老巴买了西方石油以后
我就有个
念头就想
这其实是一个买油的一个
很有意思的办法
就是买个油田存在地底下
它不会受时间损耗
那我说那我就买一点
拿着呗
可能放个20年
我觉得20年以后油肯定不是这个价钱
谁知道
我对油没有那么了解
所以我也不是很高的比重
但是我就是有什么
我就在雪球看见了我就说了
大家就很当回事
你要跟着我100%投进去
那就是你的事
这跟我也没关系
那我投的比重非常小
因为很多用户他倒也有自我的认知
说自己对具体的公司
理解是有限的
但是他认可一些人
他对公司有理解
那么他发明那种
投资方法叫抄作业
你觉得抄作业这个东西
它是不是一种可持续的投资的方法
它很难
因为你抄作业你是滞后的
首先
你抄老巴的作业
还OK
老巴的东西都是透明的嘛
你抄我的怎么抄
我又不公布我的持仓
那我买得多买得少
你根本就不知道啊
你比重跟不上
我可能就是买个东西
我就逼自己多看一看
你也跟着就一看
啊 阿段也买了
我就All In了
你的All In不就错了嘛
所以我觉得这个很难
你不懂企业确实是很难
我觉得不懂企业最好就是
最好不要碰
我非常保守
A股我就只是买了茅台
那么你就觉得
买指数比抄作业要好
我认为你要买
不能说买指数
因为指数有好多种
不是所有的指数都可以买的
老巴讲的指数指的
其实就是标普500指数
它并不是所有的指数
指数可能有几千个
或者纳斯达克100指数也可以
那你在这点上
你跟巴菲特的建议是一样的
巴菲特他的建议
也是买这种指数
接下来有另外一个公司 英伟达
一个用户叫 “迷人的打新小沙暴”
他问
就是什么原因
或者什么样的思考
让你去考虑投资英伟达这样的
看起来是一个
高度变化的行业中的一个企业
我以前也以为它高度变化
但是
后来发现它们确实很厉害
他们这个生态确实很强
你看英伟达和这个OpenAI的合作
以及AMD和OpenAI的合作
你看看这个两个交易
你可以看出来英伟达有多强
英伟达是投资1000个亿
但是是给它芯片 拿它的股份
AMD是我给你芯片
我给你股份求求你用用我
你现在知道这个差别了吗
那OpenAI当然
现在所有的人都想用别的芯片
是因为它们恐惧
英伟达的垄断
太贵了
它们要花好多的钱
因为它们之间是在军备竞赛
所有的这些大厂
AI你要赶上去
你都得要去买它的芯片
所以
它们是非常的希望
再拱出一家来
这样它们可以有个价格
因为半导体这个东西一旦同质化
价格就一下就下来
就没有办法做到这一点
它不是一天两天了
所以它们确实是厉害
然后
我也看了一下
黄仁勋很多视频
我觉得这个人我也很欣赏
我觉得他其实十多年前讲的东西
和今天讲的东西是一样的
他其实早就看到了
他一直在朝那个方向做
所以你现在就不得不去想
他现在讲的东西
依然是他对未来的认同
他还在这样做
所以我觉得
投一点是
看看吧
觉得
AI这个东西我觉得
至少掺和一下
不要错过了
完全错过了
好像有点不太合适
那么
我理解你这个
一 AI你认为它
至少是一个有需求的东西
那个
我自己用AI
我用了 我觉得
太好用了
就方便太多了
然后你认为
其实像英伟达这样的公司
在这个行业里面
它的竞争力是有一定的可持续性
至少目前还是这么认为
如果它是一个
同质化的 没有持续性的
你就不会考虑投资这个
当然不会
我以前是觉得半导体很难做的
任何一个东西
所以我不会在英特尔上面亏钱
因为我没有碰过
我以前也没有投过半导体
这也是我
我错过英伟达的一个很重要的原因
其实我早就看到
但是
没有关注
直到说这两年AI起来了以后
以前是觉得就是偶尔的
被炒起来的一个东西
我现在觉得不像是炒起来
仔细关注关注很有意思
这家公司真的蛮有意思
可能甚至对
包括像台积电这样的
企业
你也有一些兴趣
台积电呢
这公司其实我早就知道
因为我们原来拿芯片是从
就是台联电
因为台积电是不会直接供芯片的
它是做代工的
它只是帮人加工芯片
那我很早
30多年前我就跟台联电说
我说你们做芯片
你们是做不过台积电的
因为它们是专注在做那个
台联电那个时候又做代工
又做自己的芯片
又开发各种各样的产品
我说你长期是做不过它们的
这不幸而言中
你看台积电和台联电
你看这个天地之差
当然它们后来把联发科分出来了
但是台联电的代工
你没有见它有什么特别厉害的地方
现在都听不见了
不知道它们在做什么
所以我其实很早就知道它们
只是说这个行当我不懂
我觉得他们很重资产
但是现在发现了
就半导体啊
这个AI啊
这种起飞法
好像谁都逃不过台积电
它把所有人都干掉
以前我们还要去找
三星啊
包括最早IBM也很厉害
英特尔也做很多芯片的
现在这些人一找代工都是去找
台积电
那我觉得
这个还是有点意思
所以我也买了一些
但最近这个价格涨得太离谱了
虽然
离谱归离谱
其实也没有说就那么贵
如果未来的发展真的像
黄仁勋讲的那个样子
它现在的价格是有道理的
但是我不知道
也是因为这样
其实你在这些
在公司上的投入的力度是有限的
没有到我敢像投苹果那样
投苹果我投最高的时候
我投到90几个点
就是一直买一直买一直买
每次掉我都买
当然现在我也卖了一些
因为我会卖点call（看涨期权）什么的
它有时候就call走了
一涨就call走
call走就call走了
我也可以买点别的
那我们（从）英伟达和台积电
这样的公司延伸出去
我们讲技术进步 商业创新
尤其是技术进步
它会创造很多新的商业
发掘新的需求
然后它也会摧毁一些
老的商业
会
那么通常创新对这个企业
会有很高的需求
甚至会有一些运气方面的需求
他们说是创新成功的幸运者
那么也有一些公司呢
它处在不需要那么多创新的一个行业里面
那么这两个相比
你更倾向于哪一种的
倾向于我能看懂
倾向于我觉得它未来赚到的钱
是匹配我的投资的机会成本
所以你看我也买茅台
茅台这个公司就是不要变
就怕来个新的CEO
他就东搞搞西搞搞
到目前为止还好了
他们再变也不敢
万变不敢离其宗了
你不要把53度飞天给变了
这个就惨了
所以国营企业在这点上是有好处的
我听说像有些民营企业
像什么老干妈
我不知道是真是假
我听网上说儿子上来就把配方给变了
我说这种事在茅台可不敢有
那个很危险
你好好的为什么要变
创新这个东西其实就是用户需求
你需要变你就变
不需要变就不要变
那你像科技行业你必须得创新
因为你新的东西会出来
会满足更多的用户的需求
你要不变你就死了
铁死
那茅台的口味这个东西已经形成了
你再去改口味那就是脑袋坏了
这肯定不应该这样
但我不知道
你想可口可乐它们也会改变一下口味
但是它原来的口味是一定要保留的
但它会逐步的去
因为健康的原因
因为这个原因
因为那个原因加一些新的东西
那从搞懂的角度
这两种是不是要搞懂一家
需要创新的企业会更难一些
这不知道 那看他是谁
这个其实搞懂茅台也不容易
我就看每个人每个人不一样
你看多少人搞不懂茅台
也很多人搞不懂苹果
我也搞不懂英伟达
也没搞懂谷歌
我要早搞懂谷歌
其实我一直都很喜欢谷歌
但是就是搞不懂
我现在有点懂了
但是 又开始担心了
AI这个东西
但它们AI本身也很厉害
但是 就搜索的这个生意
会有多大的程度被AI
这种像ChatGPT 包括Gemini本身
会取代多少搜索 我是不知道
那么对谷歌我理解是这样
你说你很喜欢这个公司
对
可能很喜欢的是它的文化
对 它的生意模式以前是很强的
但是你说你搞不懂的
那个环节在什么地方
就是我刚刚讲过的呀
它的变化
它的这个变化
AI这个变化
会到底对它产生多少多大的影响
我现在是不知道
虽然我不知道
但是我总的来讲
我觉得这家公司还是挺好的
所以我前段时间还买了一些
你要搞懂不变的东西
或者搞懂创新的东西
其实都挺难
当然 搞懂啥都难
但是再难也没有高尔夫难
我们再说一个
特斯拉这个公司
你这些年对它的看法
是不是也有些变化
没有什么本质的变化
但是
确实觉得埃隆·马斯克这个人是厉害
他有很多想法
也确实是很先进的
但是 投资呢
我觉得我比较难
个人的角度来讲
我不说很喜欢这个人的品行
你投资实际上你在跟着他做朋友
我不想跟他做朋友
哪怕给我钱我也不干
所以我没有那么喜欢这件事情
但是 我认识到他确实是厉害
而且他的东西
有很多东西很有道理
有些东西很没道理
你不知道他哪一条先出来
那这个主要是关于这个人
他的生意呢
觉得怎么样
电动车这个生意不会太好
会很累
它差异化很小
但是
特斯拉的电动车
它是做出差异化的
大部分电动车的生意呢
我觉得是会很艰苦
那特斯拉总体来讲
它确实是做得好
你看它款式也少
这东西也很单一
量又很大
那它相对来讲
成本就会低
它是很可能有钱赚
这就是我很早我就
你想
我在博客上是写过特斯拉
我最早是很喜欢特斯拉
你看我的车牌都是“我们爱特斯拉”
后来就看马斯克那些事
我就觉得
有点不太喜欢这个人
加上我
我买了他们车以后
看它们的服务各方面
好多我没那么满意的东西
这又把股票也卖了
当然这是个错误的决策
我可能应该留着
但是我觉得很难
确实很难
我真的没有那么喜欢这个人
但是
我尊重他
我觉得他确实有很多东西
是做得很了不起
尤其是你看他这个SpaceX
那个太牛了
非常厉害
而且星链也很厉害
电动车我不知道
我觉得就那么回事吧
我不是很喜欢特斯拉车
但是我喜欢它的星链
我是它的客户
然后你看SpaceX
我觉得确实也是厉害的
你看到那个
能够把那么大一个东西
就让它降下来
我觉得太牛了
这是个牛人
毫无疑问
肯定比我牛太多了
但不意味着我一定要喜欢他
我们还是回到那个老巴说
不要投资四个轮子的生意
你觉得电动车这个东西
或者以及现在大家搞的智能驾驶
这个东西
它会改变四个轮子
这个生意的本质吗
很难
因为车本身
电动车
它比汽油车要简单
就是一个电机
然后你什么形状
其实它都可以做
那么最后
势必慢慢慢慢
大家就是
价格竞争会越来越多
当然如果你真的打得
就剩一个两个牌子的时候
它们可能达成默契
它们还是有钱赚的
智能驾驶这个东西
如果每个人都自己搞
其实也很累
我不知道
我不在这个行当里头
我是觉得
也可能将来
大家都用谷歌的方案
或者是用某几家的方案
那最后大家也是同质化的
就是大家的东西也都差不多
最后大家就赚个平均利润呗
就是说你不是说就没有钱赚
但是你要赚到很好的利润
因为它没有很好的差异化
所以它也很难有很好的利润
但是如果大家要是卷的话
那卷到什么程度就不知道
那个一定是要卷完了
才会有剩下的人能够赚钱
现在我不知道有多少家
在做电动车
就像我们当年做游戏机一样
可能有几百家
你卷到最后就剩几家
那几家是赚钱的
但这几百家都是要倒的
所以你现在看到的电动车
大部分都会死掉
这个我可以肯定
谁会活下来我不知道
那你总体上倾向于
无论是电动还是智能化
它并没有改变这个行业的根本的特征
它就变成了
它把汽油车改了
可能有一天
但我不知道啊
电动车是不是真的能够节能
能够环保
我其实一直都没有搞清楚这件事情
因为你从宏观
从长远的角度来讲
电池本身是一个不太环保的东西
所以我不是很清楚
你生产电的过程就很难讲了
当然你要太阳能真的使用的很好
那可能电动车就真的是
会变得特别有益
如果将来真的人类实现了核聚变发电
那确实它是有意义的
但是我没有很深入的研究过
但如果真是那样
那汽油车就活不下去
汽油车就很难了
但是电动车之间
它们会依然继续卷下去
它们的差异化是比汽油车要小的
就是无法改变这个行业的竞争
强竞争的特征
但汽车行业的竞争没有比方说
太阳能硅片的竞争那么强烈
也没有航空公司的竞争那么强烈
因为航空公司就是A到B嘛
你是出100块
那我就也顶多就卖100块
它没有什么差异化
最后就是靠航线
航线垄断
那航线呢
你没有办法真的垄断一个航线的
因为政府总是会多给两条航线
让你们来竞争
汽车也是一样的
那现在像特斯拉这样的公司
它现在花了很多的精力去做这个
另外一项业务
就是人形机器人
你觉得这个东西是有商业价值的吗
我不知道
它要做出来
当然他说的
那你家里配几个机器人
连保姆都不用请了
那当然好对不对
还可以提供情绪价值
多好啊
能不能做到
有人就觉得肯定可以 所以就去赌
我一般不会
我就觉得除非我真的看懂了
真的能做到
我不是太理解为什么要有人形机器人
因为机器人是不需要人形的
是不是人形并不重要
你这个炒菜机器人
你为什么要长得像个保姆呢
当然它如果是能够做到
又没有什么代价
那也许是有道理的
因为人有人的好处
它两条腿走路它灵活很多
你要是四个轮子的话呢
有很多地方你可能去不了
那两个腿你可以上楼梯下楼梯
就有好多因素可以导致
那所谓的两个腿的这个东西是有道理
但是你是不是要有头我就不知道了
因为我想像当中是没有必要
你可以有四肢你可以有八肢
你好多个手都可以
还可以飞起来
对
飞起来那个就复杂一些
我觉得飞起来可能性不大
因为你家里就那么点大
你怎么托起那些重量
户外是可以的
那我再说一个最老的公司
伯克希尔
老巴刚刚退休
它过去算是基业长青的公司了
那么现在也有很多持有它的股票的人
这是有疑问的
比如说这个人
“江畔初月初照人”他说
伯克希尔
就是他退休了
他这个公司能不能基业长青
那他可能对这家公司完全不了解吧
怎么会有这样的问题
老巴买的这些公司都在
第二
他接班人他的文化是承接的
他们都是在努力的找现金流好
未来现金流好的公司
这一点是不会变的
那么至于说这个人的水平怎么样
那老巴有犯错误的时候
那老巴找的人也不会说差到哪里去
那它这个文化是不会变的
它们不会是一家投机的公司
你拿着伯克希尔哈撒韦
你肯定比随便买一个共同基金要好
比从你网上买的基金肯定是要好很多
那你有什么好选的呢
你如果不懂投资
那就应该买像伯克希尔哈撒韦
或者像标普500指数这样
那一定是比买（基金）好
这些你知道它们是谁
你知道它们的历史
对不对
我觉得你买这个可能比什么黑石
比这些东西要好
我觉得长期来讲
它的回报很可能是比它更高
如果这样子说你觉得他的公司能持续的
维持之前的优势的概率是大的
我觉得他们的方式
他们的方式方法
他们的思维方式是成立的
至于说他们能不能够跑赢标普500指数
不知道
老巴我也专门跟他聊过这个事
你觉得你未来还可以跑赢标普500指数吗
他说非常难
但是他觉得呢
可能可以跑赢一点点
他就是喜欢做这件事
不然他就买标普500指数
他就彻底不管了就完了
所以他们的机会成本就是标普500指数
所以他们只有在
他们觉得可以跑赢标普500指数的时候
他们才会出手
不然他就不干了
不然他就买标普500指数就好了
就可简单的一件事
我都是这样想的
你要哪天我真的决定
我也不打算做投资了
或者说我传给小孩的时候
发现我某个孩子是不懂投资的
你也没办法搞懂
不懂的人
你有时候你是没办法的
你就给他买标普500指数就好
或者是买伯克希尔哈撒韦
结果我有个朋友过世了
他的孩子就跟我讲
他就是买了一半的标普500指数
买了一半的伯克希尔哈撒韦
这就对了
这安排挺好的
对
然后他们就不操心了
他们也不管你市场
怎么怎么样
反正他们就过自己的小日子就好了
因为标普500指数有分红
那一半的股票的分红
那足够他们花了
那伯克希尔哈撒韦就拿着呗
这样他会省好多心
那再问一个大家更关心的公司
就是拼多多
你之前说对它是有风险投资的
那么最新其实你也是有增仓的
那现在还是个风险投资吗
还是
还是 但是好一点
我懂得多一点
所以我
我其实曾经卖掉过很大的部位
我又差不多又都买回来了
我觉得这公司还是有点意思
但是是有风险的
我不推荐别人买
你说你又买回来
你觉得更懂了一点
你觉得懂了是什么部分
人家赚的钱摆在那儿了
你看财报你都能看见了
它现在其实
如果它能够维持这个生意
它是很便宜的
问题是我不知道
它是不是真的能够维持
有什么样的东西会影响到它
但是
我对他们整个文化整个团队
我是信任的
但是大环境我不知道
一个用户叫“张浩_”他问
比如说5到10年之后的拼多多
你现在是没有办法建立一个清晰的预期
我觉得大概率他们应该活得还不错
但是不是百分之一百
我觉得苹果
我可以说
我很肯定的知道苹果还会活得很好
拼多多呢 我没有那么清晰
我觉得
这个行当的变化其实也很大
但是它存在一种可能性
就是它会比现在还要厉害很多
那风投就是这个意思
对不对
那不是风投
我就应该买很大的比重在里头
我并没有
只能用不是那么多的仓位
去投资这个公司
但是我觉得是值得拥有一部分
你对团队的认可
其实是增加了一定程度的
你投资它的确定性
你的这个中国公司里面
比较大的持仓的茅台这个公司
你经常说
白酒分两种 茅台和其他
那你能说一说
茅台和其他的区别是什么
跟不喝酒的人说茅台不是好怪吗
就是喜欢的人
他喜欢茅台
他喜欢那个口味
他习惯
你要跟一堆不喜欢
不喝茅台的人
你就没办法讲那个事情
你就跟鱼讲
路上行走的乐趣
如何讲
没有办法
但是
它是一个事实
喜欢喝茅台的人
他们一直在喝
只要他们能喝
喝得起
有条件喝
就这么简单
那么你的核心
是茅台的独特的口味
和它的目标消费者
对这个独特口味的认同
你最重要
它有没有一个文化
可以维持这个东西
它如果
把这个出品的文化改了
多干快上
多快好省的这个
大干快上
那它是要出问题的
我觉得茅台
到目前为止还好
我没有看到这样的问题
我觉得他们对
那些最基本的品质的标准呢
他们坚持的是很严的
所以我还是可以蛮放心的
我们确实蛮多茅台
大概就这样
一个是它有独特的口味
然后目标消费者对这个口味有认同
另外你从公司的角度
你觉得它能维系这个口味
它是国营企业
国营企业有国营企业的好处
我在国营企业也待过
这些规矩
不太有人敢改
太多的人盯着
所以我觉得他们应该是可以
可以走很远
茅台这样的
你认为这个方面稳定性很强
比如说它估值非常贵
我举个例子吧 50倍市盈率
你觉得你会把它卖掉吗
市盈率是讲的在某一个时刻
你比方说它这一次
搞一个单笔冲销某个东西
当前的市盈率可能会突然就上去
因为决定投资不是由市盈率来决定的
是由你未来的现金流来决定
你关键看你未来的这个
我不能跟你讲
它市盈率要是到了50倍我就要卖
当然如果它是正常的情况下
它就是疯涨到了50倍
就比方说今天的茅台的价格
突然再涨个三倍
那我可能也是会想卖
其实2600 2700的时候我是可想卖了
因为觉得那个时候其实已经
相对来讲那个时点是贵的
我当时最犹豫最犹豫的就是
我们的仓位太大了
我卖了以后我买什么
我就开始折磨自己 对不对
然后放眼看去我什么都买不下手
然后现在掉下来了
你要卖了就好了
是
你那卖的那些人
不是亏得更多吗
因为你买了别的 对不对
我敢保证大部分人是更亏的
除非你卖了以后
就一直拿着现金拿到今天
那你确实牛
我做不到
我是一个满仓主义者
我不买一个股票呢
我心里头就会不舒服
拿着现金是一件很难受的事情
尤其人民币你拿现金
你存银行里才一点几个点的利息
你不难受
你不得买点啥
买完不就都亏了嘛
对不对
你还不如拿着茅台知道它早晚会回来嘛
我可真的就是想通了这个问题
当然了
你事后诸葛亮
你也没想好它会一下掉那么多
对不对
当然这跟大环境也
其实也没掉多少
从2600掉到1200
掉了50%
其实是没多少
你一个股票
你要是扛不住掉50%
你就不应该买
我是觉得是OK的
所以我们后来其实还买了不少
我们其实有闲钱会一直买
就是说之前2021年的时候
大概2600的时候
你觉得从未来现金流折现的角度来说
你不能说那个价格是很有吸引力的
其实就是取决你的机会成本
我卖掉了以后钱放在哪
我并不能够得到更高的回报
其实它的分红还是比利息高
所以你就拿着
其实我并没有亏
这是股价上大家看着
如果我要是当时卖掉
我不就多赚了嘛
投资不能这么想
投资这么想你早就卖掉
那些2600的时候该卖的那些人
可能1200就卖掉
对不对
所以他们拿不到那个时候
所以拿到那个时候
他可能将来会拿到3000 4000
都是有可能的
我觉得茅台将来一定会回来
但是什么时候我不知道
可能五年十年 没有人知道
关键这个钱你如果不在茅台上
你必须要有个地方去嘛
那你去哪里
这个很重要
你要回答不了这个问题
其实讨论投资都是瞎扯
那如果当时有个你认为
可以无缝切过去的
你将来自由现金流折现比茅台好的
其实你是会换的
当然会呀
投资是要卖的
我觉得很多人对所谓的价值投资
有个很大的误解就是
你要长期持有的意思
就不可以卖了
长期持有是一个意向
就是我买的那个刹那
我是打算长期持有的
但是你永远是算你的机会成本的
如果你发现一个更好的公司
你觉得更踏实
比方说你五年前看懂了英伟达
假设你看到了今天这样的局面
你手里只有茅台
如果能够换的话
你没有道理不换
但你也看不懂
你就不要扯这个事
那就没关系
有个人问了一个
跟酒直接关系的
叫“稻妻浪子”
他说同为高度酒
为什么威士忌 伏特加
可以在中国流行
五粮液 茅台却没办法在（国外）流行
中国白酒有国际化的机会吗
我不知道
我觉得茅台是肯定有的
中国白酒
我都说茅台和白酒是两个东西
好 就说茅台吧
茅台就是中国人所到之处
很多人喝茅台
他们到了这也喝茅台
他说在这里面指的国外
肯定不是华人喝茅台
你花功夫了吗
那你没花功夫
你怎么就让人家喝了呢
酒是一个很长久的文化的东西
你如何能够让大家喝茅台
人家都没听说过
对不对
但是中国人都听过威士忌
喝威士忌的人
也都是这些商务人士
我是宁愿喝威士忌
我也不喝茅台
因为好的威士忌
它要柔一些
茅台还是对我来讲有点冲
但是你看我们三十年庆的时候
我们晚餐就有30年的茅台
那个还是挺好
那30年的茅台真的不错
我家里有些30年的茅台
那就十几年前我买茅台的时候
我买了一批酒
但是因为我不喝
我要喝我早喝完了
那些其中一批30年的茅台
存到今天
那肯定是很好喝
偶尔会有朋友来的时候
开个一瓶两瓶的
确实很柔很不错的
再问一个
一个叫“非完全进化体”的用户
他说投资茅台
需不需要看宏观的环境
我不觉得需要
投资本来你就是看十年
二十年
当然如果宏观环境一直都不太好
那你投别的也很惨
这个其实并没有区别
还是取决于你这个钱放在哪里
像茅台现在这种情况
放在那里
你股息可能都能拿到
你目前投资的3% 4%了
那肯定比放银行好
当然比亏在别的地方会更好
但茅台会不会再掉
完全有可能
那你要有钱就继续买
当然我也不想买成他们的大股东
他们也不想卖给我
对不对
但是多买一点我总是可以的吧
我们接下来问一些
更轻松的一点的问题
更开放性的
都很轻松嘛
这一个叫“于扬”的用户
他问
对AI的看法是什么
是一个泡沫还是再一次的工业革命
它肯定是个工业革命
但是
泡沫总是会伴随而来的
泡沫的特征就是
阿猫阿狗都跟着一起涨
你现在就是
凡事只要一说AI
大家就冲进去买吧
但是
最后会有一些公司
它在里面确实是会很厉害
因为我们学哲学
有个量变到质变的过程
那其实AI没有什么了不起的
AI就是计算机应用
它不是上了一个量级
它是上了一百个量级
一万个量级
它这么个上法
真的就改变了
你想以前
我记得我们这个
计算机里头还要讲算法
你要省空间
最后那个存储器起来了以后
空间变得就不重要
还是重要
但是就没有那么重要
但是你看到了这个地方
DeepSeek搞了个算法
它又可以让它更省成本
更省成本并不会
因此（让）大家不需要算力
它会激发更多的算力
你现在用AI的人越来越多
英伟达也不会
因此它就卖不动了
所以AI肯定是
是一个
带来很大变化的东西
但是到底多大
会带来什么样的东西
什么样大变化
我其实也没有完全想懂
我就想工业革命的时候
比方说蒸汽机出来
有了机器
你慢慢就有了工厂
就把农民赶到了工厂里头去了
那这个生产效率确实大幅度提高
那么GDP确实就提高了
后来又有了
比方说汽车 飞机
大家的活动范围又大了
那么GDP其实也是会跟着高的
但是AI到底会怎么样
我现在不知道
但是我知道很多人的工作
肯定是要出问题的
我以前我要看一家新公司
我可是不容易搞懂
现在可容易了
你就找AI
你就问
问一个问题
它后面会跟几个问题
你一个一个问
你可能一个小时半个小时
你就对一个完全不知道的公司
有个大致的了解
然后我可以决定
我是不是要再深入的去了解
这个效率太高了
那你再想医疗
你想那些做药物研究的人
做医疗研究的人
以前可能你要一个团队
搞好几年的东西
现在可能就一个人
花两天就搞完了
这个东西将来
你不知道会带来什么样的变化
非常的恐怖
可能还有很多
你看现在
你连动画到底是真人还是假的
你都不知道
那电影行业的人
是不是就很难受
作家们我估计也会难受的
你想写个小说
我都能写了现在
我要想模仿方三文的口吻
写一篇小说
它真能写出来
但是模仿人发言
它肯定是可以做到的
但它不一定是真的
但它可以做到有点像的
但投资这个东西它取代不了
它对投资行业
可能有什么影响呢
炒股票的人会很危险
因为你炒不过梁文锋了
这个早就发现了
所以你全是韭菜
你想看图看线
去炒股赚钱的人
你就是铁铁的韭菜
但是它收割不了我
因为我就不动
我也不交易
我买了茅台我就拿着了
你要砸下来我就买呗
因为最后你想
因为买公司最后
这句话很少人有懂
真正的公司的买家
只有一个人
就是公司本身
它是靠它的盈利
最后会把自己买回来
但是它的变
衍生的状态有很多种
所以只要公司
最后赚钱赚到你淹到脖子的时候
它不得不买回来
茅台也有这个问题
最后它不得不分红
分红你自己买吧
或者它回购
我觉得茅台它早就应该回购了
但是它终于开始回购一点点
实在是没有办法
钱多了不好受的
它不知道这个钱花到哪去
它干脆就买自己股票
要趁它便宜
那你的意思是说
可以看到的
AI对炒股是有很大的影响的
对投资可能影响没那么大
投资没有影响
它不影响我做的决策
你要是在看图看线做日内交易者
你都是找死
大概率你会比以前更难赚到钱
那些量化基金
它们速度非常快
它确实电脑在操作
它有人工干预的
所以你就更打不过它们
所以我觉得小散户你要想靠
赚点短线的钱
看图看线
大概率是
只要时间足够长
这比去澳门也好不到哪里去
那么这里面
现在还就是关于AI行业
有个很大的争议
对AI能够提高效率
大家已经没什么争议了
大家争议的是
通过这个来提高效率的话
它到底是一种减员增效
还是它能创造新的需求
新的场景
新的GDP的增量呢
我不知道
我觉得它可以创造GDP的增量
但是
它减员
在某些地方
有人肯定是会被减掉的
但不是所有人都会减掉
所以我觉得每个人可能都要
很认真的对待这件事情
不要说自己学不会
其实是可以学会的
我都可以学
你为什么就不能学
我觉得AI会对每个人产生影响
大人也好 小孩也好
我看过很多人
四十多岁以后
就觉得他不能够再接受新东西了
其实那样
我觉得他的日子会过得很难
很痛苦很难受
新东西有时候还是挺好玩的
但是它怎么样创造增量
是不是你现在也不是那么清晰
至少很多公司
现在增量已经明显的出来了
但是说
这个增量是来自于
其他人减下来的吗
我不知道
你看这些包括Meta
包括谷歌
微软
甲骨文
Adobe
你看这些公司
它们都明显有增量
包括腾讯
AI开始用了以后
广告效率 很多东西
它一下就起来了
它确实提高了效率
而且它还可能还省了人了
生产安装线我不知道
我没有办法去想所有的行业
因为这个问题很大
这个问题当然也是我
我也很想知道
我还前两天
专门跟一个获过诺贝尔奖的经济学家聊过
他说他也看不懂
就觉得这是一个很神秘的事情
但是我觉得大概率它是会增加的
它是会增加的
它像工业革命一样
它提高了效率
它很有机会增加GDP
从回顾过往的话
凡是一个东西它提高了效率
长期来看是它都会产生增量
你能举出反例吗 关键是
举不出反例
是啊
所以你能够举出反例的话
那就表示它不成立吗
如果这么多年下来
好像我想了一圈
我也想不出反例
效率提高了
整个GDP下来了
好像不太可能
你说某个人的GDP下来了
那是太有可能了
你的工作都丢了
你的收入都没了
就是火车
比如说让马车夫失业了
但它显然创造的
当然
这速度快了很多
载运量 速度
都是大幅度提高
你的生意范围一下就宽了嘛
所以我认为
我猜吧
应该是可以的
这里有个叫“辰義承”的用户
他想问一个孩子教育的事情
当然可能刚才你已经回答过了
大概就是在子女教育方面
父母能做什么
父母
我又不是个儿童教育专家
我觉得 我在想
父母做的所有的事情
其实就是为了给孩子增加安全感
倒过来
降低安全感的事情就不应该做
比方说打孩子啊 呵斥孩子啊
那你说你不打 他就不听话
你要找别的办法
我觉得孩子们其实不需要靠打
但是打
打出来的孩子可能更孝顺
那是吓的 他就养成习惯了
但是那个对他一辈子的发展
其实是不好的
他不开心的
当然
有些家长根本就不在乎孩子开不开心
那你想做什么做什么
我觉得爱孩子的人不应该那样
但不是说意味着你可以溺爱
你就可以没有原则的
他要什么就给什么
那这里面确实是有一些边界的东西
不容易 不好把握
但是真的要花功夫去做这件事
但是你有个不为清单
不要做伤害孩子的安全感的事情
这是清楚的
我觉得这个很重要
就是凡是
因为家长给孩子做的所有的事情
其实都是在教他怎么做事情
所以你骂他就是教他骂人
你打他就是教他可以将来打孩子
你跟他发脾气
就表示他可以发脾气
你对他好
他就表示他觉得他要对人好
那孩子是永远有脾气的
而且孩子是可以在某一个时刻
他会用他的语言表达他的情绪
比方说我不爱你了爸爸
我不爱爸爸
他就是那一个时刻
他有什么东西他不高兴了
你可不要带上身了
觉得他真的不爱你了
所以这个事你就不要理他就好
不是不理他
你就打点马虎眼
找点别的事
他可能也就好了
过一会他又开始又我爱你
又亲你的
我觉得这个时候你又可以很开心
关键就是不要跟孩子杠上
我了解到
你在教育方面
是做了一些公益的投入的
是的
很多地方都做了
后来我多少也参与了一些公益的项目
你觉得你在做这个公益的过程中
对这个教育的看法有什么变化吗
因为我也见过很多
比方说我跟小孩做球童
那我看过很多家长做球童的时候
你小孩打不好球会发脾气
那很多家长就跟着一起发
骂小孩
你怎么这个球都打不好
那个家长怎么是这样子的呢
其实这个时候他是最需要支持的时候
他已经很生气了
我的观点就是
我这个时候就是抱抱他
拍拍他
他有时候不理你
不理你就等一会
他过一会就好了
你不能想的每时每刻
他都要听你的话
我记得以前我儿子哭的时候
不要哭了不要哭了
男孩子哭什么哭
爸爸你就让我哭一下嘛
我一想
这孩子说的对啊
让他哭一下有什么问题
你就让他哭
哭一会就好了
什么事都没有
你不能跟他杠上了
不许他哭
还要采用对抗的形式
我觉得就挺不好
打孩子就更不好
打孩子其实也不解决问题
我又不是没打过孩子
我打过
我就想打打看
管不管用
发现完全不管用
这样我就赶紧跟儿子道歉
说爸爸错了
爸爸以后永远不会再打你
我确实就没有再打过孩子
我不觉得那是个好的办法
我觉得我们现在关系也挺好
那我再问一下
你觉得教育
在一个人的人生的发展
或者成功的路上
它到底有多大作用
教育的定义是什么在你这边
教育
那它包括学习知识 学习方法
应该是这样
接受价值观方法论
知识
我觉得教育当然是很有作用
非常有作用
所以受过良好教育和
完全没有受过教育的人
完全不一样
甚至你从眼神
从面相就能看出来
一个人受过教育还是没有受过
我可以给你举个简单的例子
我记得以前在小霸王招人的时候
有个人拿着华南理工大学
那个时候叫华南工学院
无线电系毕业的文凭
就来我这儿找工作
从进门我就看出来了
我说觉得不像读过书的人
就不像上过大学
那我也不能这么质疑人家
人家文凭都有嘛
我就说哎
你们第一年都上啥课来着
数学 物理 化学
我说那是中学的课
你就没上过大学
上过大学不会这么回答这个问题
你真的是能够看出来的
当然他是大专毕业
你可能不一定看得出来
你没上过大专大学啊
你真的是装不出来的
有个文凭没有用
那你说我是一句话没有说啊
我就一眼就看出来
从进门我就觉得
哎
这个人为什么会来啊
就是这种
然后想了一个很奇怪的问题
一下就问倒
就问他哎呀
你没上过大学
我们是招工程师啊
这个东西你上去就露馅了嘛
你肯定是啥都不懂嘛
他说哎呀我想找份工作
找份工作你找别的呀
你这个肯定不行
找份保安都行嘛
但是确实有这样的人
拿假文凭混
但是这个人肯定是不动脑筋的
你要拿个假文凭
你也不要拿这个呀
这个东西见光死的呀
所以我就说教育
尤其是学习的能力很重要
但是学校里头并不都教这些东西
但是小镇做题家
他通过做题
他可能有些人就会学到这个
我也是小镇做题家做出来的
当年我确实做好多题
我们那时候因为没有书
也没有地方可以学
我们那个情况比较特殊了
后来可能要好很多
我是觉得做题是挺有帮助的
但是不是每个人会去悟的
同样做题很多人会做死
我是觉得你从里面要找到方法
从你犯的错误里头
你去找到
你为什么会错
然后你就学会了整个逻辑
那问一个特别宽泛的问题
这个是叫“别犹豫别后悔”问的
他说
那么你未来还有哪些愿望想要实现的
你说我吗
我这个人本来就胸无大志的
我就过好每一天就挺好
那未来的愿望也是过好每一天
做自己喜欢的事情
其实没什么了不起的
我从来不是一个我要做点大事
干点事情的人
我觉得那个东西
那我每天在干什么
我每天都在干点事情
那就是你做你自己享受的事情
做你自己能够喜欢的事情
我觉得很重要
而且因为你喜欢你才能做得好
所以不能倒过来讲
你现在都成功了
所以你才这么讲
它不是的
你不要把本末倒了
那是因为我在做自己喜欢的事情
所以我会很认真的做
所以我就做好
公司也是一样
我找到同样喜欢的人
然后我可以交给他们来做
我还可以做自己喜欢的其他的事情
比如说经营企业我已经享受过了
我觉得确实挺好玩
那确实也挺累的
那最后一个结束的问题
你对普通人的投资有什么建议
没什么建议
我觉得投资就是投资
跟你是什么人没有关系
你不是好好的投
你反正最后就还不如不投
你要真不懂投资
你就不要碰
不要想着去看见隔壁
王二麻子赚了大钱了
你就也想去赚一票
他还不一定是真的赚
只是那么说而已
炒股是很难赚钱
大部分的散户
牛市熊市都是亏钱的
80%吧
所以你不要觉得你就是特殊的那个人
除非你知道是为什么
现在就更难了
现在又有了
量化基金这种东西
以前就有
但是
以前没有那么厉害
现在它更厉害
就越来越厉害
AI越来越厉害
所以炒股票确实是
反正你一买它就掉
你一卖它就涨
人家就是冲着你来的
但是
你要是真的会投资呢
你不需要什么建议
你买了你觉得好公司你拿着
你跟你自己的
其他的机会成本比就好
所以我老是说茅台
我就觉得茅台可能是
比较容易懂的东西
当然很多人说年轻人不喝茅台了
可那些不年轻的人
他还能活很久啊
这是第一
第二 年轻人一直都不喝茅台
那以后你可保不住他会不会喝
喝酒有害健康
这个是真的
但是
它有情绪价值
所以还是会有人喝
我自己就喜欢喝酒
我本来想着
今天我要不要带一瓶酒过来
边聊边喝呢
后来是因为
我的运动的任务没完成
所以我不能现在喝酒
我不知道你们有没有
坐着聊天边聊（边喝）
弄杯红酒
倒没有这么浪漫过
是可以考虑的
可以
下回试一下
那么大体上你的建议就是
炒股是很难挣钱的
我觉得很难
但是投资也未尝不可
你如果懂的话
投资的前提是你要懂企业
你要搞懂它
或者你看到合理的东西
就是你自己觉得
这个东西你觉得有道理
那你想我跟一个朋友讲
那时候他要投什么
然后他是一个特别喜欢喝茅台的人
我说你为什么不买茅台
果然就买了茅台后来
买完以后也没挣到钱
我就跟他讲
我说哎
你那些没买茅台的朋友
他们都买啥了
哎呀
你这么一说
我就舒服了
他们亏得比我多多了
我说那不就对了吗
茅台最后会回来的
再不回来
你拿股息都会拿回来
只不过就时间长一点
但是你要投到你不懂的生意里头
你会很惨
这几年不是茅台掉
这几年是大部分都掉了
所以我不是说真的要去鼓吹茅台
我只是觉得你就事论事的话
我觉得对大多数人来讲
茅台可能是一个有意思的想法
当然你说
别的看起来也还不错的
我没有发言权
因为我没有太仔细看过
比方说很多人问我
那你为什么不买五粮液
市盈率还更低
其实也是可以考虑的
但是我确实没有发言权
因为我从来没有碰过五粮液
我不知道那个酒什么味道
我这个人本身不喝白酒
就除了茅台我能喝一点以外
别的酒我喝不了
我一喝觉得好冲
所以我没有发言权
但你要是喜欢喝五粮液的人
你就会坚信
会有很多人喜欢喝
那我觉得为什么不呢
就像我喜欢玩游戏
所以我就做了游戏
那游戏市场再难的时候
我都知道会有很多人来玩的
那个东西很重要
你要是对这个东西
你卖的东西
你不知道有没有人要买
你没有办法坚持
太难了
如果你要坚定的认为
没有人会再喝酒了
那他确实不应该买
这个觉得没道理
但他本来就不喝的这些人
他也很难坚定
就像你买茅台
可能比我买茅台
可能要困难一些
因为我认识太多喝茅台的人
那么你的建议大概
如果总结一下的话
大概就是说不要炒股
炒股挣钱很难
去投资
投资也许可以挣点钱
投资是可以
投资当然可以
不然我在干嘛
好的 谢谢
我刚刚完成了
对“大道无形我有型”
也就是段永平先生的采访
在做这个采访之前
我们都有些困惑的
因为大道说
我想说的在雪球上平时都说过了
如果大家有什么想问我的
也都可以随时问我
我跟大道说
那可能我们这期节目
也就是一个老调重谈
但是谈完以后
我觉得还是不错的
还是对大道的投资的理念
他的价值观
他的方法论
有了一个相对系统的总结
我希望这个节目
对雪球上的用户
也能起到这样的作用
同时大家以后
你有投资方面的问题
也依然可以在雪球上问他